[Music]
Marvel vs. Capcom Infinite has moved
away from three character fights in
favor of a two-player tag anywhere any
time system that puts an entirely new
spin on your team synergy now if you'd
like to see some gameplay of that you
can check out the livestream that you're
at and I did last week where I swag on
him just a little but the game also
introduces or reintroduces rather if you
remember the Marvel Super Heroes game
from 1985 the six Infinity stones in the
Marvel Universe now each one grants your
character a move that they can perform
at any time during the match called in
infinity surge as well as a super
powerful ability that effectively breaks
the game for a while and that's the
Infinity storm and this leaves room for
near infinite possibilities with team
composition as your two characters will
have very different strategies depending
on which infinity stone you pick so if
you're eager to jump in and start
bodying people right away we've got you
covered we're going to take a look at
each stone what they can do and
suggestions for characters or strategies
that you should use with them
[Music]
speeding its way into the first slot on
our list the time stone offers your
characters a quick teleport and dash
ability that you can use to close the
distance between you and your opponents
or create some devious and mix ups you
might want to use a stone if your
character lacks mobility options so
people who can't fly can't air - this
might be perfect for them activating
time stones in fancy storms speeds you
up significantly and gives your
characters some nasty custom combo
abilities basically your moves now have
zero recovery time and they can all link
into each other so if you ever want to
do a combo with twenty hard kicks in a
row now's your chance as long as your
characters have normals that move them
forward slightly you'll be able to carry
them all the way to the corner with this
stone if what you're looking for is some
zoning assistance to help you out in
your neutral the reality stone might be
for you using the Infinity surge tosses
out a slow-moving projectile that homes
in on your opponent it's good for
creating space and can be super annoying
to deal with so giving it's characters
that lacks a zoning abilities is a good
option or you can just use it with an
already projectile heavy character like
zero or Dormammu for added pressure and
before you snap back to reality
make sure you use the Infinity storm
which spits out massive elemental
attacks with every normal move you
perform light punch shoots out little
bolts of energy like kick freezes
opponents hard punch charges up a huge
beam of fire and hard kick summons a
pillar of electricity all the attacks
are great for cover while you rush down
and it can easily catch opponents who
try to run away from you while the
infinity storm is active also one thing
to note is that you can only send out
one elemental attack at a time but that
limitation is per character so what you
want to do is send down an attack tag in
your character and then you can have two
of them on screen at once
allowing you to use them for some pretty
wicked combos
the mind is a terrible thing to waste
and the mind stone is no different you
don't want to waste any opportunities to
use the stones surged ability as they'll
perform a grab which then leaves your
opponent dizzy for a few seconds and as
for the infinity storm the mind stone
causes your team to constantly regain
meter throughout its duration now this
is great for all characters but
especially those with powerup hyper
combos like X or firebrand and
characters with hyper combos that
persist on the screen like Dormammu and
Rocket Raccoon just make sure to use
your meter you don't want to be at four
bars while the infinity storm is still
going and then you just waste all that
meter I'm sad to report that this stone
does not in fact launch an awesome 4
player 3d re umbrella at the opponent
but instead using the infinity surge
throws out a short-range attack that
causes a wall bounce you can use this as
a combo extension or as a powerful
anti-air tool and it's a great stone to
start out with while you learn how the
combo system works as the Infinity storm
doesn't actually change your play too
much well other than the fact that your
attacks will do a ton more damage and
cause gigantic wall bounces so if you
like piling the hurt onto your
opponent's the power stone is definitely
the way to go
[Music]
as far as toying with your opponents go
the space stone has a lot to offer using
the stones infinity search pulls the
player towards you
not unlike Magneto and storms moves in
Marvel 3 but since you can cancel the
surge with the hyper combo characters
with grab supers will probably benefit
from the stone the most got a pesky
spider-man playing keep-away with you
pull them in and smash their puny little
spider bits to pieces
the stones infinity storm otherwise
known as putting them in a box traps the
opponent in this little enclosure and
gives them few ways to defend themselves
they can't switch characters or even
move beyond the confines of the box it
effectively creates a corner for
yourself so think about using characters
that can utilize some quick high-low
mix-ups or characters with teleports
like Dante or even stick with your big
body team and command grab them today
they've got nowhere to go so let's make
them comfy with a nice piledriver
the mayor
and finally to cap off this madness we
have the soul stone it's not too
impressive at first with an infinity
surge that does a quick but low damaging
life drain but hold on to your butts
because once you've build enough meter
it offers one of the craziest abilities
ever seen in the Marvel vs. Capcom
series you know how when your character
dies they just kind of stay on the
screen instead of vanishing into thin
air like previous games
well the infinity storm for this puppy
brings that character back to life with
15% health and echoing the Street
Fighter Alpha dramatic valves and that
one glitch for Marvel 3 allows you to
control both characters on screen at the
same time if you're unsure if this game
could rival the insanity of previous
Marvel games this is all the proof that
you need right here the soul stone opens
the floodgates for an entirely new set
of combos to style on someone with and
really hammers home the infinite in the
game's title now you don't have to wait
until one of your character dies but
being able to revive them puts a lot of
pressure on your opponent to think twice
about when to kill you your movement and
button inputs will be identical for both
characters so you'll probably need to
spend a lot of time in training mode
trying to figure out which moves to
perform and when but really it all
depends on what characters you pick
characters with teleports projectiles
and good rushdown abilities will do
really well with the stone Dormammu for
example is a great partner to have with
this as he can easily charge up his
powers while hyper combos going on in
the foreground allowing you to rain
Hellfire afterwards
so those are all six at the Infinity
stones in Marvel vs. Capcom infinite
there's also one more thing that applies
to all the stones and that's the fact
that only one infinity storm can be
active at a time so you'll need to be
smart about when you use it for example
if your opponent has the soul stone and
you just know that they're about to
revive their second character you can
activate your own infinity storm to
block the theirs but that's just one
small part of the meadow there's still
tons of tech to discover and this video
is just a primer so get into that
training room and putting some work now
if you have any strats or team comps
that everyone should be aware of don't
save it for Evo just put it in the
comments below and don't forget to check
out the review of the game on GameSpot
calm while you're at it
my name is Joey and thanks for watching